good morning 6 30 is the time here on
this Thursday if you're waking up and
then don't have your eyes quite open yes
those were goat sounds they are not
coming from your house on the television
yeah well I have a goat we don't know
yeah there's a caveat there you might
have goats yes but I think maybe I
figured out the goat yoga thing oh you
did what if it's yoga for goats is that
what it is oh that's not what it is I
know well what I bet a goat could do
downward dog
I have not understood this story at all
all morning long I'm trying to make it
work
nah I must say
I think you should just give up and just
accept it except what is and move on yes
that is so philosophical Sharon well
sometimes you just gotta give in you're
gonna get my goat give up the go give it
up all right let's take a look at our
last sunrise of summer for 2022. that's
right Paul is not officially here yet
isn't it gorgeous it is so pretty
outside we had a few breezes out on the
west side but those have calmed down it
is nice and clear let's enjoy our last
oh 11 and a half hours of Summer shall
we lots of 70s but also lots of 60s too
it's kind of split half and half this is
just a sampling of some of our Valley
neighborhoods West Henderson on St Rose
Parkway still a little Breezy there I
gotta remember not to touch the screen
66 degrees there 70s from Nellis to
North Las Vegas to Harry Reid kiddos it
is a very nice morning 70 is the average
I kind of average the 60s and 70s clear
a little cooler this morning not as
windy this afternoon lots of good
Sunshine 91 is what we're aiming for
right at normal for our last Afternoon
Of Summer and we'll talk about the
arrival of fall and then the warm-up
that's coming right behind it all right
let's get to the roads check the drive
here's Nate with a look right now okay
you can touch the screen don't swipe the
screen maybe that's it yeah you were
swiping it I like to swipe when you do
that there you go hey there's Houston
traffic that's not what we're here for
we're here for your traffic and that
includes the freeway is getting a little
more crowded and here's that red spot
that is very annoying hopefully if this
is your ride every day you figured this
out we're talking about the westbound
215. now the through lanes are great as
you're going past Las Vegas Boulevard
past the 15 to Decatur and Beyond but if
you're looking to get off on Las Vegas
Boulevard or on the 15 that ramp is down
to one lane it's been this way for weeks
so just get used to it that delay we
don't know when that's going to be
changing now coming up on our next
report a huge delay on the Strip the
Northbound lanes are closed from trop to
Flamingo we'll talk about it in our next
report Heather maybe Houston does look
better Nate thank you the Federal
Reserve announced another jumbo interest
rate hike affecting things like car
loans mortgages your credit cards and
Federal Reserve chairman Jerome Powell
made that announcement yesterday as
anticipated it's the latest effort to
curb raging inflation rates but it's
also causing a dip in the stock market
leaving a lot of folks concerned about
what it means for their 401k and
retirement plans UNLV economics
professor Stephen Miller says this has
the power to really impact those who are
ready to cash out their 401K because
they're also facing a higher cost of
living
they're going to be hurt by this not
because of the stock market but rather
because the FED is is going to be
controlling inflation through aggressive
policy Miller says no matter how close
you are to retirement he recommends
having a myriad of Investments with
different risk levels he says while it
is impossible to predict he and other
experts are hoping to see the economic
climate level out by the end of 2023.
the National Association of Realtors
reported home sales dropped in August
it's the seventh month in a row
stubbornly high home prices along with
higher mortgage rates are some of the
key factors in why prospective home
buyers are being pushed out of the
market
Metro Police have identified the two
officers that were involved in a recent
shooting this is video from the scene we
do have body camera video as well but a
warning it does contain gunshots
dozens
that's a police say officers Marlon
Salazar and Devonta Gleason fired at a
suspect who was carrying a pistol and in
that video there you see the suspect
that's 37-year-old Stephen Travato
running away from officers assistant
Sheriff John McGrath says the officers
could not take any chances
that's a high crime area where we knew
that there's been an increase in
burglaries and auto burglaries so that's
why the officers are going there and
then he confronted us with his weapon
before we could even talk to him travada
remains in police custody while he's
hospitalized he did have outstanding
warrants and is now facing new charges
as well all right Heather a man in
Henderson is fighting for his life he
was hurt in a hit-and-run bicycle crash
and police are asking for your help to
track down the driver with a really odd
set of circumstances well it happened a
week ago Sunday night that was September
11th at Saint Rose and Maryland Parkway
911 certainly a tough day for anyone
especially those are the title law
enforcement and now it's even harder for
this local family who responded to that
terrorist attack 21 years ago and are
now fighting to keep their husband and
father alive here's our Ryan Matthey
I see a perfectly healthy functioning
man who is laying there incapacitated
unable to communicate
and unable to move Jennifer volbis hopes
her husband 53 year old Mark vobas will
recover he was a first responder on 9 11
in New York City decades later First
Responders came to his Aid after he was
hit riding his bike Henderson Police say
he was struck from behind just before 8
at night the driver taking off it feels
really unfair
more than a week later markings from the
scene remain where Mark was found
unresponsive pieces of his bike still
there it sounds like there's a lot of
missing pieces in this investigation is
that right absolutely there are yes
evidence that Henderson police officer
and traffic investigator Mark Rasmussen
says are far and few between the
location not in your business or
residential cameras is there the
possibility because of the entire
situation that you would not be able to
solve this
there is a possibility but we don't want
to give up hope and we're certainly not
going to stop where we're at we're going
to continue to investigate this as long
as we can if you could speak to your
husband right now if he was to to become
conscious again what what would you tell
him right now
I would tell him I love him
that we will get through this
you're just
strong
we'll figure it out Ryan Matthey 8 news
now Anderson Police asking you to help
out any information call Crime Stopper
702-385-55555
remain anonymous there are cash rewards
for information leading to an arrest
Heather so to come here on good days
something new coming to a strip
Marketplace but what about all the
people who are already running shops
there ready to hear from local business
owners as soon as we come back Terry